From Mantis and Drax's adventures in
Hollywood to a terrified Kevin Bacon,
and even a special cameo by Kingo,
the "Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special"
is filled with Christmas cheer…and Easter eggs.
Marvel Studios has gotten more creative with
its opening credits sequences in Phase 4,
especially with music cues. "Eternals"
replaced the typical Marvel theme with
something reminiscent of a vintage
Western. "Thor: Love and Thunder"
put a power ballad spin on it. But Marvel
Studios' first ever special presentation,
the Halloween special "Werewolf by Night,"
made the most significant changes to the
status quo with its new title graphic, its black
and white claw slashes, and its screams and howls.
"The Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special"
continues this emerging tradition with
its Christmas-themed opener. As The Pogues'
Christmas song "Fairytale of New York" plays,
the usual comic graphics of Marvel superheroes
are interspersed with images of Christmas trees,
garlands, kids ice skating, and, of
course, the big guy himself: Santa Claus.
While the "Werewolf by Night" opener ends with
some black and white flashes of lightning,
the intro of "The Guardians of the
Galaxy Holiday Special" ends with
the words "Marvel Studios" lit up in red
and green Christmas lights. These cheeky
alterations aren't just a nod to the season.
Santa is actually part of Marvel Comics' canon.
On the subject of music choices, "The Guardians
of the Galaxy Holiday Special" features two
live performances by professional musicians.
First up, alternative country band Old '97s
are decked out in holiday attire. They've been
transformed into four different alien species,
all of whom are playing their Earth
instruments for the first time. They
do this as they try to write a new song and
"historical document" about human Christmas.
"Everything I know about Christmas, I
learned from Rocket, who learned from Cosmo,
who learned from Kraglin, who learned from you."
That new song, "I Don't Know What
Christmas Is (But Christmastime Is
Here)," is full of hilarious misinterpretations
of Christmas stories and symbols. For example,
the alien band thinks that if children misbehave,
Santa puts dung in their socks, as opposed to coal
in their stockings, which a frustrated Peter
Quill insists isn't "part of the lore" at all.
Later, Kevin Bacon joins the Old
'97s to perform one of the group's
pre-existing holiday numbers,
"Here It Is Christmas Time."
Bacon isn't just a movie star and the subject
of the game Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon,
he's also a member of the band The Bacon Brothers
alongside his sibling Michael. The Bacon Brothers
play a similar style of country folk rock music
to the Old '97s, so when this fictionalized
version of the actor chooses to stay of his own
volition to celebrate the holidays on Knowhere,
he picks up a guitar and fits right in with
the alien entertainment. The holiday special's
soundtrack includes some other fun auditory Easter
eggs, too, like The Strokes' Julian Casablancas'
rendition of the "Saturday Night Live"
Christmas song "I Wish It Was Christmas Today."
Writer and director James Gunn said that "The
Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special" will
fill in some important narrative gaps
and prepare fans for "Vol. 3," which
is scheduled to premiere in May of 2023.
Those appear to be these two new facts:
The Guardians are the proud new owners of
Knowhere, and Mantis is Peter Quill's half-sister.
Let's start with Knowhere. Viewers might not
realize that this is where they are when the
special begins, but Nebula tosses off a line
in which she explains that they've purchased
the world that was once a Celestial's skull
from the Collector. We also see Knowhere in
the background as Mantis and Drax fly away.
This confirms that Taneleer Tivan is still
alive and strongly implies that Knowhere will
be at least the partial setting of "Vol. 3."
By the looks of it, the Guardians have done a
commendable job of rehabilitating the one-time
mining colony and outpost into a tight-knit
community that's beginning to thrive again.
As for Mantis, she's afraid to tell Peter
the truth about their relationship because
she suspects it might remind him of his awful
father, Ego, and his mother's death at Ego's
hand. Of course, Peter is thrilled
to have someone he can call family,
but it remains to be seen how their kinship
will impact the Guardians going forward.
News broke that Maria Bakalova had
been cast in "Guardians of the Galaxy:
Vol. 3" shortly after her star-making
performance in the second "Borat" movie
though nobody knew in what capacity. While she's
expected to play a much larger role in the film,
she has a fun cameo-sized role in two scenes
of the holiday special as the new voice of
Cosmo the Spacedog. Cosmo has appeared
in the MCU before in "Guardians of the
Galaxy" where the dog is behind glass as
part of the Collector's collection. Cosmo
also appears in the end credits of "Vol. 2"
and "What If... T'Challa Became a Star-Lord?"
The character originated in the comics,
where he's male and part of the Russian
space program. The dog was based on a real
canine space explorer, who also happened
to be female. With Bulgarian comedian and actor
Bakalova's casting, Cosmo has been gender-swapped,
retroactively rendering her female in her previous
MCU appearances. But, presumably, she retains the
same backstory. The already species-diverse
"Guardians of the Galaxy" can only get more
delightfully absurd with the addition of the
uproariously funny Bakalova as Cosmo the Spacedog.
Sending Mantis and Drax to Hollywood created a
perfect opportunity for James Gunn and company
to have fun at their own industry's expense.
The two most socially inept Guardians walk
confidently down Hollywood Boulevard in
their search for the hero Kevin Bacon,
but they pause in front of the famous
TCL Chinese Theatre. In a fun Easter egg,
the actors who play the two Guardians have put
their real handprints and signatures in the
concrete just to the right of where Mantis and
Drax are standing during their photo session.
Instead of Chris Evans or Scarlett Johansson
in their Captain America or Black Widow suits,
we see people in Spirit Halloween-quality Avengers
costumes posing for pictures with tourists.
Besides Cap and Natasha, there's an
Ant-Man, a Captain Marvel, a Thor,
and a Jack Sparrow for good measure. Mantis
and Drax mistake the counterfeit Captain
America for the real Steve Rogers, which
leads to an embarrassing moment. But soon,
they realize these selfie-happy MCU fans are
a money-making opportunity, and they gladly
snap some group pics before continuing their
quest for the best Christmas present ever.
If you look closely at one banner in
particular near Hollywood Boulevard,
it advertises Kingo's latest project. In
our world, we might all be watching "The
Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special,"
but in the world of the MCU, the public is
getting "Kingo's Christmas." A large vertical
billboard marketing the actor-slash-Eternal's
special can be seen on the side of a building
before Mantis and Drax enter the bar.
Kingo, played by Kumail Nanjiani,
is an immortal being, but in
"Eternals," he's biding his time on Earth
as a celebrity who keeps reinventing himself
as his own son or grandson, so as
not to arouse suspicion about his
eternal youth. The MCU's version of Kingo really
enjoys being a celebrity. He also fits Mantis,
Drax, and Nebula's impression of actors as
self-absorbed fame chasers who aren't heroes.
"He's an actor! He's never actually saved anyone!"
"But actors are repugnant!"
"I know!"
This is because Kingo doesn't show up to help the
rest of the Eternals in the climax of that film.
Another Easter egg that works as a multilayered
joke with multiple meanings is the inclusion of
celebrity star maps. When a drunk Mantis and Drax
come to a dead end in their hunt for Kevin Bacon,
the owner of a souvenir shop overhears their
conversation and offers the alien duo a map of the
stars. These maps are big business in Hollywood,
though they're not always reliable, so the
idea that Mantis and Drax could use one to find
Kevin Bacon's house is a joke in and of itself.
Since she lost her money, Mantis deploys her
powers to steal the map and the rest of the
cash in the woman's fanny pack. A graphic
appears onscreen that purports to show the
locations of the residences of a handful
of celebrities. There's Queen Latifah,
John Cena, Arnold Schwarzenegger, and
a photo of a young Mark-Paul Gosselaar
from his "Saved by the Bell" days. Once
Mantis and Drax get to Kevin Bacon's house,
the house number, 1988, is a reference to
the year Peter Quill was taken into space
by Yondu. Star Maps is also a sort of double
entendre since the Guardians of the Galaxy
exist in space and frequently travel between
planets using maps of various star systems.
"The Guardians of the Galaxy"
movies largely take place in space,
and many scenes take place aboard spaceships.
That means there are tons of vehicles in the
"Guardians" movies, and most of them have
pretty innovative and recognizable designs,
as well as clever names. Peter Quill started
with the Milano, named after '80s and '90's TV
star Alyssa Milano. He upgraded to the
Benatar, named for singer Pat Benatar,
which can be seen in "Avengers: Infinity War,"
"Avengers: Endgame," and "Thor: Love and Thunder."
"The Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday Special"
introduces the Guardians' newest ship,
the Bowie, named after rock icon David Bowie.
Star-Lord commands his crew to get Kevin Bacon
aboard the Bowie and fly him safely back
to Earth so that they're not on the hook
for human trafficking anymore. But once in the
driver and passenger seats of the spacecraft,
Kraglin and Kevin Bacon have a heart-to-heart.
Kevin decides to stay a little longer to teach
everyone on Knowhere the meaning of Christmas.
The Bowie first appeared in the comics in 2019,
so the holiday special is simply making the
ship officially part of the MCU's canon.
Once everyone starts exchanging gifts, the
Easter eggs in "The Guardians of the Galaxy
Holiday Special" get even wittier
and more self-referential. Nebula,
who isn't exactly known for being warm and fuzzy,
gives Rocket a sizable rectangular box.
He opens it to discover a metal appendage.
"Bucky's arm?" he asks, to which
Nebula says, "Merry Christmas."
She doesn't want to acknowledge it, but
this is an incredibly thoughtful gift,
not to mention an expensive one – Bucky's
most recent arm was made out of Vibranium.
In "Avengers: Infinity War," Bucky and
Rocket fight side by side. At one point,
the former lifts the latter into the air and they
take out their surrounding enemies with a circular
barrage of gunfire. Afterward, Rocket tries to
negotiate a price for Bucky's gun…and his arm.
"How much for the gun?"
"It's not for sale."
"Okay, how much for the arm?"
This callback to "Infinity War" also calls
back to the first "Guardians" movie. In it,
Rocket instructs the newly banded Guardians
to steal a prosthetic leg in their attempt
to break out of prison. When it comes
time to put their plan into action,
he reveals that he didn't need the
leg, he just thought it would be funny.
An older teenage Groot carves little
wooden dioramas for all of his friends
in the "Guardians" holiday special. He hands
out the wrapped boxes and each member of the
Guardians opens theirs. Mantis' diorama
depicts the beginning of the live-action
part of the special when the Guardians were
standing on a balcony talking about how Yondu
ruined Christmas. Peter Quill gets a carving
of Mantis and Drax chasing a terrified Kevin
Bacon down the street. Drax receives a miniature
version of himself flipping over a police car.
Nebula's scene recreates the moment everyone
gave Kevin Bacon, still under Mantis' control,
to Peter Quill as a gift. In other words, the
presents Groot has given his friends tell the
story of the holiday special. That leaves
Kraglin, who opens his box last. For him,
Groot has carved a small Kraglin opening an even
smaller Kraglin opening an even smaller Kraglin.
The "Guardians of the Galaxy" films have given the
MCU some of its weirdest supporting and featured
characters, and the wackiest might be Taserface.
This numbskulled and aggressive space pirate has
been in the comics since 1990, but he made
his MCU debut in "Guardians of the Galaxy:
Vol. 2" when he tried to stage a mutiny and
came into conflict with Rocket Raccoon. Rocket
repeatedly mocks his name, to which Taserface
infamously replies with a full-bodied shout.
"It's metaphorical!"
Taserface didn't make it out of that film alive,
but he popped up in "What If...?" where, in an
alternate reality, he and Kraglin pick up T'Challa
instead of Peter Quill. We don't see an animated
Taserface in "The Guardians of the Galaxy Holiday
Special," but the character still gets a shoutout.
As Yondu goes through the garbage
can of presents and decorations
that he destroyed and threw away
in a fit of anti-Christmas rage,
we can see that one package has been designated
for Taserface. The sloppy handwriting is likely
a clue that young Peter remembered Taserface
and got the angry Ravager something special.